the g-pro x is one of logitech's premium
headsets
thanks to its minimalist design and
luxurious feel it aims to appeal to both
hardcore gamers and audiophiles alike
but how well does it fare in both
aspects
we only find out after the b-rolls
[Music]
what's up everybody this is geek culture
i'm marion and today we'll be reviewing
the logitech g pro x headset so before
we get into specifics
let's see what's inside the box so
besides the g pro x you have a couple of
cables including a console pc cable a
mobile cable with a button
a pc splitter
a detachable mic
a usb external sound card
a pair of memory foam leatherette pads a
pair of memory foam cloth pads a
carrying bag as well as a stand
so you have a nice little bit of utility
there depending on what situation you're
in and what devices you're using the
g-pro x is modeled after its predecessor
the g-pro but it comes with it a couple
of interesting new tweaks this one comes
with an even more luxe
very classy design as stated with the
leatherette pads on the head as well as
on the ear cups it comes with a nice
monochromatic finish as well as a very
sweet touch of silver lining
just to give it a little bit more class
so to complement its streamlined look
it's actually really lightweight as well
so it doesn't feel
awkward on your head
it also doesn't have a very clunky look
which makes it nice to hold as well so
what makes the g4x great for gaming is
firstly it comes with a noise canceling
feature once you put it on your ears
you're rest assured that you cannot
really hear much interference outside
secondly it produces fantastic clarity
in its sound reproduction especially in
your mids and your highs
now that said the bass is sufficient but
i wouldn't say it's the strongest among
all its competitors but still if you're
a dedicated audiophile this still packs
quite a bit of punch just note that the
mids and highs are slightly stronger
which actually still makes it great for
music and apart from its noise
cancelling effects it also doesn't come
with any sound leakage so it makes it
great when you're listening to it in
public so now we know the g4x channels
sound really really well but that's not
all it has to offer so one of logitech's
newly acquired subsidiaries is blue
which also makes really good audio
products and with that partnership comes
with the new mic that is powered by blue
voice technology
so let's cut right to the chase
we have the g pro x plugged into our
second camera here
so i'm going to be wearing it and i'm
going to be speaking on the mic and you
decide for yourself how well the
microphone sounds alright so this is how
it's going to sound like on the g pro x
microphone powered by blue technology
just note that this might not be how it
sounds like on a pc or a mobile device
but still you can tell just how crisp
the sound is this cardiac mic picks up
quite a hefty bit of sound
as you can see even when i speak really
loudly
or even in a whisper
it's really great if you even want to
shoot a podcast or if you just want to
make a call even if you are speaking in
a loud environment the person on the
receiving end can hear you quite well
and that shows just how great the blue
voice technology is on the g pro x so
that's just how the blue voice mic
sounds when just hooked up to a camera
this is without any of the innate
functions that it comes with speaking of
which let's dive into the g hub app just
to show you how versatile blue voice
technology is so as you can see now we
have the g pro x hooked up to a pc with
logitech g hub running as well so thanks
to g-hub and the blue voice technology
it turns your g-pro x into a toolbox
full of sound that you can adjust on the
fly
so if you look at the app itself it
comes with a couple of presets that you
can obviously swap to on the fly you can
also create your own custom presets and
in every one of these presets you can
adjust the eq
of your sound whether you want to
increase the bass whether you want to
get more mids or more highs it really
depends on the situation you're in so
thanks to blue voice technology it opens
up a lot of avenues with which you can
project your sound
so
there's a couple of presets here that
you can play around with so typically
for broadcasters streamers and
podcasters want to be using the settings
broadcaster 1 and 2.
there's a couple more fun settings here
such as am radio which makes it sound as
if you're in an old school kind of radio
setting
fm station which sounds
like you're in a more modern radio
setting so i'm gonna play a couple of
different playbacks here just for you to
hear how they might sound like
hello testing
hello testing hello testing
as you can see there's
really quite a lot of utility that blue
voice technology brings to you so it's
not just a really powerful microphone
it's also a really versatile microphone
like that so even for gaming you have a
couple of presets that are just catered
to fps games as well as mobile games
oh yes if you were to enable surround
sound you can even adjust
how much sound comes in at different
angles so it really gives you a super
immersive experience it's very akin to
getting a home speaker system
it's really great considering how much
utility is packed into these headphones
perhaps one of its biggest weaknesses
aside from its clunky naming convention
is the fact that it is not wireless so
this might be a debatable factor for
some of you but in an era where a lot of
wireless technology has been coming up
especially in gaming peripherals the
logitech g pro x kind of misses out in
that aspect it is
with all due respect still a really
great headset
it just would have been nice if it came
with the wireless version as well the
logitech g pro x is by no means a budget
headset it actually comes with a premium
price of 229 singapore dollars you're
getting not just quality out of its
build
but most importantly out of its sound as
an added bonus it comes with a really
sweet sounding microphone powered by
blue voice technology and that is not
something that many headphones can boast
logitech really did the r d here and it
shows in the quality of the g pro x
thanks to the comfort it offers
its cellar build as well as its sweet
sweet sound anyone in the market looking
for a new pair of headphones can look no
further than the logitech g pro x and
that wraps up our review of the logitech
g pro x headset
do let us know your thoughts in the
comments section also if you want to
check out our full written review
there's a link of it in the description
below
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and once again i'm marion and this is
geek culture signing off
[Music]
you